the Warlords of the sea are one of the
strongest groups of pirates in one piece
some of them are nearly as powerful as
the empress and some simply have
ridiculously overpowered devil fruits
and yet none of them has ever managed to
become king of the Pirates so far at
least but what would have happened if
Luffy had eaten their crazy devil fruits
instead and even though it would
obviously be a ton of fun to think about
Luffy having mihawk sword skills since
we're talking about devil food
specifically for this video the focus
will be on crocodile's absolutely
powerful sand fruits yakomoria Sinister
Shadow fruit the flamingos manipulative
string fruit and Bartholomew kumas
unbelievably overpowered paw fruits the
pirate Empress Boa Hancock was also one
of the original Warlords but her fruit
makes absolutely no sense for Luffy so
we're just not gonna include it so we do
begin in Luffy's childhood where kid
Luffy is eyeing not only one but five
treasure boxes that shanks's crew has
left lying around the bar now one of
these contains
original devil fruit and the others have
the warlord's devil fruits that will
assume that
bushings also steel and so the always
hungry Luffy sneakily steals a treasure
chest and takes a bite of this weird
looking fruit inside and as he's
munching away Shanks and the crew go
absolutely Bonkers Shanks grabs his arm
and instantly a little Shadow clone of
Luffy comes up from the floor to slap
away shanks's hands May introduce Shadow
Luffy and before we get into all of
these surprising changes that this would
have on the story let's talk for a
second about devil fruits and
personalities here because in a previous
video I explained how there's pretty
strong evidence that devil fruits
contain some sort of will of their own
or a soul and when someone eats a devil
fruit then the fruits will will affect
the person who ate it for example
gekkomoria the original user of the
Shadow fruit is pretty damn lazy and
uses other people's Shadows to do his
dirty work but what's this Moria just
utilizing his fruit or was the nature of
the Shadow fruit encouraging him to use
the powers in this way similar
doflamingo string fruit can literally
make people into puppets so was it just
the perfect fruit for no flamingo or did
the fruit encourage him to become an
evil underground puppet master who
manipulates people and we can even see a
little bit of this with Luffy during his
fight with kaido where Luffy is laughing
uncontrollably after Awakening his
original devil fruit powers and so
because Luffy is eating a different
devil fruit his personality may actually
change slightly he may not be the guy
who always bounces back from the feet
because that was the main characteristic
of his original devil fruit also it
would probably be someone like Ace who
would get his original Fruit instead but
we're not gonna Focus too much on that
and so with this personality influence
of devil fruits in mind let's dive right
into the shadowy powers of the Shadow
fruit now basically this fruit allows
you to manipulate shadows both your own
and other peoples on the Zombie Island
Thriller bark we learned that Moria can
take Shadows from other people and then
use them to bring corpses back to life
or to master actively increase his own
strength as we've also seen with Shadow
Luffy also his own shadow basically
becomes a second version of himself that
can act independently so in other words
it is a seriously powerful devil fruit
however for Luffy this fruit is probably
the absolute worst match out of any of
these four wall or devil fruits I mean
any of the other fruits in this video
fit his personality way better as we'll
be seeing in just a moment but this one
right here is going to present major
obstacles for Luffy and that's because
the downside of taking away someone's
Shadow is that they will die if they go
into the sunlight so this leaves us with
two options first is that Luffy doesn't
ever take someone else's Shadow meaning
that he doesn't use the fruit's main
power or second is that his personality
is completely changed and different by
the devil fruit and in this case Shadow
Luffy would no longer really care about
other people dying so he is totally fine
stealing Shadows from anyone he means
needs and defeats but while this clearly
didn't bother Moria I simply cannot
imagine Luffy taking Shadows from
innocent people and then just leaving
them to die or hide in the dark for the
rest of their lives like that's just a
completely different character so if he
isn't going to steal Shadows that
basically leaves Luffy with just his own
shadow to manipulate which is still
pretty badass because it is basically an
unkillable copy of yourself so let's see
how far Luffy can actually go with these
kind of unfitting powers for him after
training for 10 years with Garb and Ace
and Sabo I think Luffy would definitely
learn how to use his shadow clone
incredibly well he could make it appear
block attacks fight for him and even
seamlessly swap places with his shadow
so while I don't think that he would
have any problem in the East blue the
real challenge with this route comes in
Alabaster against the warlord crocodile
as we already mentioned crocodile has
the sand fruit which turns his body into
sand and just like any logia this means
that he is a virtually out Untouchable
unless someone has already used hockey
or discovers their Elemental weakness
and in the original story Luffy was only
able to defeat Crocodile by getting the
sand wet with blood and water and even
then Luffy still suffered two crushing
defeats twice and only lived because of
a combination of luck the Allies that he
had and his rubber body of course
however Shadow Luffy would have none of
these advantages and would even be much
less skilled at combat Luffy's body in
this case is normal and cannot stretch
so he basically is just a normal fighter
with his shadow clone but since he
cannot use haki yet and his body
wouldn't be as durable I really don't
think that Luffy would survive this
encounter no matter how you look at it
and even if he did manage to survive he
would definitely lose to some other
strong fighter along the grand line in
the first half of the story and so even
though it might be a little bit
surprising to see how bad Luffy would be
with that fruit I think it is goodbye
Shadow Luffy for now and if this version
of Luffy couldn't even make it past the
first half of the grand line will any of
these new Devil fruits be strong enough
for Luffy to become Pirate's King well
let's just say some of these upcoming
story lines are gonna be absolutely
insane because while the shadow fruit
was a truly awful match for Luffy this
next one will allow him to unleash his
full Powers so reset back to chapter one
only this time hungry kid Luffy eats
this devil fruit Shanks grabs his arm
and instantly a razor sharp string pops
out and cuts shanks's hands looks like
this time in the delford lottery Luffy
won the string fruit and originally this
fruit was eaten by Don quixoto Flamingo
the warlord who took control over the
kingdom of dressrosa now this fruit is
absolutely insane because it allows you
to produce and control a basically
infinite amount of string which can be
used to make lifelike clones attach his
string to other people to make them
puppets and even stitch together
internal wounds so not only is this
fruit incredibly versatile but it is
also a perfect fit for Luffy's
creativity so he will surely take
advantage of the 10 years training to
become a true expert at using his
strings however since dolphy was a
cold-hearted monster we have to wonder
if this fruit would make Luffy become a
little bit more manipulative as well in
other words would Luffy's still gathers
such a loyal crew well I would say yes I
mean he probably would get the exact
same awesome crew because even though
Flamingo was still fiercely loyal to his
core crew so there's no contradiction
there but he was totally fine using
other people and while I don't think
that Luffy will follow completely in
dofey's footsteps here there are plenty
of ways for him to use the strings
without controlling innocent people so
he can basically use it to its full
ability and compared to Luffy's base
rubber form string Luffy is arguably a
lot stronger I mean he can fly like
Spider-Man fire string bullets and even
cut with his sharp string so I do think
that Luffy would have an even easier
time in the East blue than in the
original story if we're being honest and
so let's move ahead to the first major
challenge again crocodile now Luffy
would again have a much harder time
discovering the secret of logia fruit
weaknesses because most of Luffy's
strings attacks come from a distance he
will have a harder time learning that
his Bloods or water can actually allow
him to hurt the Sanford user however
because Luffy is able to fly around and
doesn't have to physically punch he
would probably survive way longer during
the fight and eventually learn the
secret to defeat crocodile or maybe he
even traps crocodile in a super compact
ball of string and dumps him into the
ocean or something like that after that
however the lightning fruit user NL is
on a completely different level because
Luffy does not have the natural rubber
immunity and he doesn't yet have hockey
the lightning food user would probably
destroy Luffy however it is also
entirely possible that string Luffy is
so smart at using his devil fruit that
he could make giant string conductors to
channel the lightning away from himself
now he still wouldn't be able to hit NL
unless he uses seastone so either way
this is going to be a very difficult and
probably lead to Luffy's defeat but on
the other hand maybe string Luffy is way
smarter about escaping and simply runs
way to survive here after all NL isn't a
necessary boss to fight in the story but
let's assume that assume that does win
or he just escaped and then he would
still probably need to be saved after
losing to aokiji however then water 7
and Anna's Lobby would be a breeze since
he can simply fly around I think he
would have a much easier time saving
Robin and defeating cp9 because one of
the biggest advantages of this fruit is
that he can attack from a distance so he
doesn't even need to be close to deal
insane amounts of damage to this leopard
man right here and even if Robin did get
captured Luffy could make his very own
version of the bird cage to make sure
that she wasn't taken away I mean just
imagine that plus Luffy could also make
keys out of string to unlock her
handcuffs making her rescue a lot easier
and of course Moria would just be a joke
to fight let's be real especially
because Luffy can even control the
shadow zombies like puppets and I don't
see any real changes to sabaori either
but impo down would definitely be
completely different Luffy would still
need help sneaking inside but then Luffy
can travel between level super easily he
could also slice open prison bars so
it's highly likely that he could save
his brother before Ace is even taken to
Marine Forts and even Luffy's fight with
the powerful venomous Warden would also
be a lot easier attacking from a
distance means that Luffy can easily
stay away from the warden's deadly
poison and I do think that he has a
really really good chance of actually
winning this fight same goes for his
encounter with Blackbeard Luffy could
slash the darkness man before he ever
has the chance to enact his evil Clan
but for the sake of argument let's go
with the worst case scenario and say
that Luffy got caught in a cloud of
poison gas and Ace was still taken to
Marine forts now though string Luffy
might be able to get to Ace more easily
during the epic battle I still think he
would be overwhelmed by the
monstrosities fighting on the
battlefields which leads us to the time
Skip and honestly once Luffy learns
hockey Everything Changes especially
with these new fruits Luffy is now a
Master with his hockey coated strings
and can take on anyone let's be real the
Fishman hody and the evil scientist
Caesar would be no problem at all there
would be no conflict in dressrosa since
doflamingo doesn't have his string fruit
and never took over the country in the
first place now of course big mom and
kaido would still be major obstacles but
these clashes are more about Superior
hockey than devil fruit Powers so I do
think Luffy would still come out on top
just like in the main storyline leaving
Luffy very well on his way to become
Pirate's King and so now with one devil
fruit turning out very bad for Luffy and
one working perfectly to continue on his
journey what will happen to Luffy's
Journey when he gets the two most
powerful devil fruits on this list so
once again cycling back to chapter one
where Luffy has now stolen this devil
fruit and takes a giant bite alarmed
Shanks grabs Luffy's arm and it explodes
into a cloud of sand Shanks jaw drops
and Luffy dissolves into a pile of Sands
and now armed with the same fruit that
def Beat It Shadow Luffy let's see how
far San Luffy can actually go and it
might actually surprise you with some of
the new challenges that he has to
overcome with this and so now since this
is a lokia fruit which turns Luffy's
entire body into scent it is arguably
the strongest of the four devil fruits
in this video just like any other logia
fruit user he cannot be hit by anyone
who doesn't know hockey he can transform
into a cloud of sand try things out with
a touch and even create sharp Blades of
sand to attack opponents however as we
discussed earlier all logia fruits have
some Elemental weakness and this fruit
has probably the biggest one in the
whole story water and so if sand Luffy
gets wet from water or Bloods or some
other sort of liquids he immediately
loses his invincibility and
unfortunately for sand Luffy water just
happened to be literally everywhere in
this world however I do believe that the
East blue would still be fairly easy
except maybe if this fisherman was
constantly wet there is a debate about
sand Luffy versus Smoke logia fruit user
smoker but with his body being literally
sand Luffy wouldn't even have been
captured in low town in the first place
so I do think we can just let that one
slip and even if crocodile somehow
managed to take over Alabaster without
his sand Powers this desert kingdom is
literally the best place for Luffy to
fight so Luffy would defeat crocodile
who whatever his other fruit would be
pretty easily I think but the bigger
question is how will sand Luffy do
against other overpowered logias like NL
or the Marine Admirals and this of
course will become highly dependent on
the match up so let's analyze these
fights in detail for just a minute here
against NL sand is actually a very poor
conductor of electricity so while Luffy
might not be completely unaffected by
lightning like he was with his rubber
buddy he still would have a very strong
chance since all lightning would do is
basically make his hand a little bit
hotter but while Luffy might do very
well in Sky Pia once he comes down to
the Sea he would face his absolute worst
matchup in the story against the ice
logia user aokiji and since aokiji would
have a near constant source of melting
ice and he does no haki on top of that
there's basically a zero chance that
Luffy would win this fight anyway and as
a result aokiji would probably demand of
Luffy that he subscribes to the channel
for more of these water videos or else
and then the story would progress pretty
much the same all throughout the time
skip when Luffy would finally learn
hockey now this makes the Post Time skip
even easier since he can now fight
pretty much anyone including logia fruit
users but all this changes when we reach
the most fearsome opponents big mom and
kaido and as we've already discussed
these battles are intense clashes of
supreme hockey and surely most
definitely sand Luffy would stand no
chance here and before you go crazy in
the comments let me explain for a second
in chapter 886 we're being told in a
flashback that hockey blossoms mostly
during intense battles however since San
Luffy's logia Powers gave him a much
easier time during the Post Time skip he
really hasn't had the chance to endure
the same struggles which allowed him to
truly Master hockey which then of course
comes back to bite him in this fight as
kaido and big mom would absolutely
destroy him and his underdeveloped haki
bringing an end to sand Luffy in wano
and so with three fruits down and the
most important one to go it brings us to
the final and most life-changing fruit
in this video which is unlike any of the
previous three back in the bar Luffy
takes a bite of the last mysterious
fruit Shanks loses his mind and grabs
him staring at the strange paw pads on
Luffy's hands but then Luffy freaks out
and a huge explosion of air demolishes
the entire building see and this Begins
the most interesting part of any of
these what-if scenarios because you see
the papa fruit was one of my top five
most overpowered devil fruits in a
recent video and its powers are truly
mind-boggling it was used by the former
warlord Bartholomew Kuma and its powers
allow you to repel anything this means
that any kind of attack can easily be
blocked but even crazier is that you can
repel things like air to make a
compression bomb or you can push
yourself so far that you can literally
travel across the world and yet the most
insane part of this entire fruit is that
it can even repel intangible Concepts
like pain or memories from a person's
body as well now can you imagine Luffy
learning to control this fruit and all
of the wild imaginative things that he
could do with it I mean the potential
for Luffy and this fruit are basically
Limitless for example could she push
pain out of himself to heal could he
push hunger out of himself to make it so
that he never gets hungry or how about
his stupidity could he just make himself
smarter so after 10 years of intense
training Luffy wouldn't even need a ship
he can simply push himself across the
sea to wherever he wants to go and while
I don't think that Luffy will be a
master of this fruit just yet because he
probably wouldn't know the world's
geography too well he should be able to
do small pushes to keep him in the air
and go between the next Island and right
off the bat one of the most interesting
questions with this fruit is would Paul
Luffy even gather a crew for example
while Kuma was a founding member of the
Revolutionary Army we almost always see
him alone by himself was that just
Kuma's personality or lack thereof or
was it something about this fruit that
naturally repels other people and if we
do apply that same idea to Luffy would
this fruit make him less willing to
gather a crew as a result however for
now let's assume that Paul Luffy still
May Nami but things completely changed
once they steal the map of the grand
line from this clown right here you see
Paul Luffy is super excited about the
grand line just like regular Luffy and
before NAMI can even talk it out of him
Luffy launches all three of them
straight to the entrance of the grand
line reverse Mountain but as they're
hanging in the air Nami is shouting at
Luffy demanding that he take them back
for obvious reasons meanwhile Luffy and
Zorro argue about which direction to
take and of course knowing these two
instead of entering the much safer
starting point of the grand line they
take a completely wrong turn and end up
near the end of the grand line at
Egghead islands and this wrong turn
nearly spells the end of the massively
unprepared crew of three first they land
at the secret laboratory of the genius
scientist Dr vegapunk and of course
vegapunk is incredibly interested in
Luffy's paw Powers that's because we've
recently learned that Kuma used the
fruits to Aid vegapunk's research
however Luffy would of course have no
interest in staying behind to do some
sort of science so he does launch the
group across the sea straight onto this
evil looking skull Dome and this is of
course the home of the emperor of the
sea kaido now at this point Nami is
seriously regretting ever joining Paul
Luffy as a Zorro probably but while
sneaking around the islands they meet
Yamato the child of kaido who has been
trapped on the island by her father
however of course Yamato knows exactly
who Luffy is since she met with Ace a
couple of years ago and she is desperate
to go out to sea with the trio and so
Luffy uses his paw powers to push off
the handcuffs just as kaido finds them
and he is very unhappy that these random
very weak looking Pirates have managed
to invade his castle he charges up a
full Dragon Blast and Nami is screaming
with fear but Luffy just grabs them all
pushes them out to safety all the way
back to the east blue where Nami has
been begging to go back to ever since
and after after landing the crew is
absolutely exhausted but Luffy and
Yamato think it was very hilarious while
Nami is furious and Zorro just wants to
take a nap and some boost but it's at
this point that Nami beats into Luffy's
head that she can't just skip ahead
because there are people way too
powerful for them and so Luffy does
decide to actually do things right and
build a proper crew with a real ship and
honestly with Yamato along for the ride
this changes everything because she is
nearly as strong as kaido already so the
East blue is pathetically easy for them
and they enter the grand line full of
confidence but Yamato isn't only a super
strong New World fighter she also knows
everything about haki so she's able to
teach the entire crew the basics very
early on and this allows the crew to
easily take out crocodile NL and even
give aokiji an incredibly difficult and
close fight I mean Yamato also has ice
powers and since this version of Luffy
uses the Paw fruit instead of Kuma this
means that the crew would not be
separated at Saba ODI they would still
need to escape from kizaru but with
rayleigh's help I think that they would
be able to all get away super safely
which now of course brings us to
marineford where this buffed up version
of the straw hat crew comes ever so
close to saving Ace however even still
the combined force of the Marines is
just a little bit too much and Ace is
eventually still killed which does bring
us to the time skip now it is possible
that the crew would go on ahead to
Fishman Island right away since they are
all together but I still do think that
this crushing defeat would mean that
they still decide to wait and train for
a bit before heading into the new world
however when they do enter the new world
after the time skip they have even more
motivation to take down kaido because
Yamato would definitely have told them
all about the situation on wano she
might even recognize these two Samurai
right away and the straw hats would
definitely want to help save their
country right from the get-go on top of
that the crew would pretty easily
through dressrosa which brings us to the
empress Saga and honestly this part of
paw fruit Luffy's story is a little bit
difficult to speculate about because of
course the most important part about
fighting any of the yonko is having
incredibly strong hockey but we don't
exactly know how haki interacts with
Luffy's devil fruit so unless Luffy
becomes an absolute Powerhouse with this
devil fruit he might struggle with some
of the strongest Fighters like kaido or
big mom or he might just have to learn
to fight with his bare hands and feet in
order to really use his hockey Powers at
the same time the limits of the Paw
fruit are still very much unknown so
it's possible that Luffy could just
become the most overpowered devil fruit
user and simply defeat everyone with the
Paw fruit for example could he just push
the soul out of big mom's homies or
could he push a devil full power out of
someone like kaido making him lose all
of his Dragon Powers I mean seriously
this fruit is just wild and until we
know more about it it is really hard to
say how Luffy would fare against the
strongest fighters in the story but the
biggest question for all of these devil
fruits is if Luffy would still become
the pirate king Shadow Luffy would
definitely not and I think that San
Luffy would not make it as well however
string Luffy and especially Paul Luffy
definitely have a major chance to pursue
the Ultimate Dream but one thing that
will be the same no matter what fruit
Luffy has is Luffy's Rivals Blackbeard
and Shanks are the ultimate power
standing in the way and if you want to
see what might happen if Luffy fought
Blackbeard and Shanks at the same time
for the one piece you can watch that
video right here Shanks for watching